last but not least I can I fit for a
second it's a meaningful vent you know
we're getting ready for the 2018 midterm
elections and I would argue that these
are probably the most significant
midterms in our lifetime because we are
already behind the eight ball in terms
of the conservative bench Supreme Court
but it can get worse there's no
guarantee that Ruth Bader Ginsburg is
going to stay on the bench for two more
years who knows who else will retire in
the next two years
anything can happen the next year's and
so if there's no other reason for us to
get the majority in the Senate for us
and by us I don't care how you define
yourself whether you define yourself as
a progressive a liberal a Democrat a
green or just a person who's not a part
of the ridiculous draconian insanity
that is the Republican Party however you
better describe yourself the fact is is
that we all lose if the Democrats don't
hold the line and get back power in the
Senate specifically the house at a
minimum so that we could block
legislation because they're now now
they're coming after Medicare Medicaid
Social Security I mean there's there's
any number of things that they want to
do to destroy they to destroy America
for the working class and the middle
class the environment climate change I
mean we we pretty much already too late
but maybe we can temper some of the
effects if we act now or at a minimum
not do more devastating things and the
Republican Party has shown themselves to
be willing to go even further you know
considering climate change to be a hoax
a Marxist host hoax which is the latest
thing I said all that to say is that
this the midterms are pretty important
and maybe you're not exposed to this I
don't know I don't know what you're
exposed to but I have a pretty large
following on social media and so I'm
exposed to a lot of ignorance and right
now what I'm seeing as a lot of
grandstanding about how the Democrats
just haven't done enough to get their
vote in the midterms and I'm like are
you daft
are you are you kidding me I at this
juncture at this point how could it's
it's so beyond me for people to be that
imbecilic in the face we're not talking
about in the face of ye old conservatism
which I would argue in another video
that it's just as bad as Donald Trump's
conservatism but we're not even talking
about the the the dog whistle style of
conservatism or the the the style of
conservatism that is Ben Sasse and and
Jeff Flake the type that tries to act
like they have decorum and tried to act
like they at least care but in the
actuality they vote 100 percent of the
time with Donald Trump we're not even
talking about that brand conservatism
we're talking about the brand
conservatism that literally said to
America we're not gonna risk 110 billion
dollar of arms deal for any journalists
from the Oval Office right we're talking
about the one that says it says my uncle
Donald Trump said this literally my
uncle my uncle was a scientist so I have
a knack for science and this global
warming is eyes a hoax you know this is
what we're up against we're up against
the destruction of of Obamacare
I don't yes I won't medicare for all
single-payer is what we need but if we
don't have Obamacare there's gonna be a
few million of us who are in trouble
we're talking about the destruction of
Social Security we're talking about a
permanent conservative majority for the
rest of our lives on the Supreme Court I
don't care what the Democrats have done
or haven't done all I know is that there
are psychopaths running our country
right now and we have the opportunity to
at least hold the line now I've got a
list of videos recent videos explaining
why we need a better breed of Democrat
we absolutely do we need Democrats who
will fight tooth and nail
we need Democrats who will pack the
court in 2020 once we get the House the
Senate and the White House we need a
Democrats who are going to call for
statehood for Puerto Rico and and in
Washington DC we need Democrats who are
going to be willing to impeach Brett
Kavanaugh we need
Democrats who were throw civility to the
wind because Republicans have we
absolutely need a better breed of
Democrats but holy hell if you don't
vote to hold the line against these
sociopaths who are currently running
this country please for the love of God
at least block me I'll block you on
Twitter just just just go away because
you're not helping anybody and anyone in
your personal life that is like that I
don't know if you should entertain them
but at the same time you can't be silent
about it you have to speak up because
that breed of stupidity that vain that
strand of ignorance that likes to
present itself as intellectual and and
and somehow more politically astute to
not participate politically in the face
of this madness that is the current
Republican Party that virus spreads
right it spreads so whereas you may want
to ignore it I want to ignore it the
reality of it is is we all have an
individual responsibility to not allow
that cancer of stupidity to spread
especially when it feels like everything
around us is burning down and if that
wasn't bad enough Republicans have made
it clear that our current dire situation
isn't good enough for them they want to
make it explicitly worse that's all the
time I have for you today come hang out
with me on the bonus show become a
member of the David Pakman show and
while you're at it go over to the
Benjamin Dixon show com sign up for my
blog and and in my podcast go to the
YouTube channel more importantly go to
YouTube channel click that subscribe
button and I've been seeing a lot of you
lately hopefully I'll see you again
take care today's program was made
possible in part by Blink accom slash
Pakman i love bling cast it's the really
perfect app for anybody who likes
politics and learning and if you're
watching or listening to the david
pakman show I'm sure you'll love
politics and learning and what blinka
studs is take the best and most popular
non-fiction books they condense them
into 15-minute audiobooks that you can
listen to in one sitting and you can
learn about politics philosophy psycho
economics often we don't have the time
to actually read as many books as we
would like I know that I'm at my limit
for how much I can read and this way you
can absorb the most important valuable
information from books in just 15
minutes maybe on your way to work maybe
on your way to the gym maybe cooking
vegan recipes at home whatever is your
thing and our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blinka scon
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you like it and I think you will you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for just about five bucks a
month you can go to be li NK is t.com
slash PA que ma n to sign up